[Music]
foreign
my name is Big Sean yeah
yeah what other names you go by this Big
Sean I don't like that shortcut showing
that's a bad let's take away from me it
takes away from you what is it my baby's
saying he wants to respect on his name
yeah or mine too yeah
what do you want dude I'm I'm talking
loud so everybody can hear me what do
you want why are you standing there
looking at me like that and then Tim
Smith um a friend of mine he go man
that's a jumper he's
um on snitch uh I'm not snitch but it
was The Walking Dead I guess you had
just finished doing and
um he said something else another movie
that you had done and I was like I don't
get a damn about whatever he won't what
he want with me
crew
knife
um with The Walking Dead knife it was
they signed it for me did I you know I
don't know what it is nothing's like
stolen damn
take one of those girls stolen
um when a girl stole it
because they got the picture that you
gave me when Shane first cut his hair
yeah you signed it yeah and wrote on it
um is that another girl's house she got
it she won't give it back to me we gotta
go get that back man let me chill copy
I ain't answer the ball but she had it
money now though
that that picture yeah we did 86 seven
bucks what no that's dude that's like
the original one there's no you didn't
touch that one though so you know
there's a big difference you think yeah
and then yeah man yeah man we need to go
get that man
they pay for my wall and they're half of
that roof you ain't got to help me get
it I get it I know dude now I I just
thought about that they just like put a
big old light bulb on top of my head I
thought about that picture
Big Sean where you from man lakeside
lakeside King tell everybody about
Lakeside
[Music]
they said I didn't walk in the park
like I said like I said I gotta
gotta you gotta pick your own battles
but you know somebody gonna pick at you
too
you know I'm I'm 46 years old and I have
to deal with the boys every day
especially the new age dudes these these
Steve would call it we call them four
babies
four babies that's what we call them
four babies what does that mean they
they their fourth generation of of us
and so you know they kind of worked them
with it we failed them
how so we filled them like you know uh
Lakeside King was still still Dillard
and we did the gangs and the drugs and
and the four babies were being born
when no Dad is around you know something
when a dead end around multiplication
female Can't Raise A Man there's no way
possible and she can you know a mama can
beat you and she can Crush you out and
you know whatever she can do they know
but you know her job is to protect so
she gonna spoil you and that's like
that's what a lot of dudes go wrong with
the female raising them she's gonna
spoil them at the same time you know
Mama's babies
um Daddy's hard head
talk about a little bit like who are you
raised by uh I was raised by a feminine
uh Kim and Gala Hargrove and um
um my grandmother
cleaned up for games mama
and so when I went to the foster home
because my mama killed her husband
and business her girl came got me
and she gave me a place to live you know
and she told me how to love myself how
to love period And so you know I gave
him a hard time the first year I was
with them but then you know they they
the more they showed me that you're a
human being you know don't be always mad
at everybody because I still got working
on that I know you know working on that
well you should show me not to be mad at
everybody all the time don't do it you
know give everybody a chance and I've
tried them too I tried people you know
they if they if they betray you again uh
just I'll deal with it good
old-fashioned way
when you talk about your childhood
though in Lakeside before you came to
live with them can you just talk about
some early memories from Lakeside I
don't remember Pace 13 years old you
mean you don't remember earlier because
uh my mama killed Mike my mama killed
her husband I was seven years old and
the way the story told that I was right
there and so whatever they did to me it
made me forget from the age of uh seven
to 13 years old I didn't I don't
remember none of that can you just talk
talk about your mom a little bit and
what kind of lady she was that's what
you remember about her she was a she was
called a female gangster you know she
was uh she go to
um
um with this man from the bottoms and he
he was a
back then and he used to beat up and as
long as she was high she didn't care but
then when she went out he beat up she
shot him one day in the net
and he died she let him lay there all
day and she cleaned up the house and got
herself makeup and stuff like that and
she did us some more dope and you know
when that was over with she called 9-1-1
and they can't pick them up but then he
had been dead like two days and she did
all that time she just she recently got
out of jail probably maybe
she's not nine years old so it's been
five or six years and I've probably seen
it like three times the first time I saw
her he's in a store and I looked at it
and I go Deborah I said look at me she
said I can't
and so she said we'll have to do it
around me just walked away
and then the second time I saw her I
went to my grandma's house for Christmas
and that was like right before the
pandemic and she was there and
um she was all in the house and I sat
outside you know just I'm I had to get
to the point where I get I get used to
being around them again because you know
even though even though I'm a part of
that family they still like I'll throw
[__] in my face like oh you've been
hanging on white people too long you
know because I learned how to talk a
little bit you know I learned how to act
a little bit you know but then you
you know yeah you still got to watch
them you know I default all of them and
I didn't beat them all up and now they
like I I feel like some of them trying
to defrain me and I don't know like
publicly but I'm putting it into that
too you know but you know I just mostly
it's because of that because of you
coming and living over here with with
white folks yeah it did you know I never
thought I was better than nobody I never
ever had that feeling thinking I was
better than nobody I'm a big dude so I'm
gonna either be in the way or is it not
enough for me
like a big old billboard you know I walk
in the club I go to work everybody they
turn around like look
like when Carmen got married
um
got married I was late and I was the
last one to get there and so you know a
lot of them really don't really don't
know me so they just know of me that I'm
a part of the heart grow family so you
know I walk in the door and I close the
door and they all turn around I go stick
them up
boy
hey that's why my mom was laughing but
everybody else was like what's going on
what's going on you know anybody said
ball of y'all [__] get your ass
out of here you know that holiday call
the police not the police you know these
toys
everybody because you know they I really
scared them yeah so they don't say I'm
gonna be in a way or it's not enough for
me
so you know I don't look down on nobody
but you know I I give everybody
that changed they halfway give me or
whatever but you know
I ain't kissing no ass for long tell me
a little more about
um I just always been interested I mean
I
I've seen your mom walk by but but we've
never we've never met because I don't
think you guys were talking at the time
but can you tell me more about like do
you have any memories of of her her man
of her husband it was Craig right yeah I
I was seven years old so you know it
just uh like that kind of said one in my
it wasn't it wasn't my business and so I
did learn from other things people what
did you hear about him what did you hear
about your mom like what kind of things
was she doing my mama did you see my
mama grew up in a place called uh
Porterville Georgia it's like a play a
slave plantation and uh the the Big
Daddy there was named Sonny Higgins and
he all the women before you get married
he kept that thing before you go off and
do your thing and that's your dad yeah
they say that's who my dad is but I
don't I don't I don't know dude when you
say I don't know it was a part of a
sharecropper I mean what like yeah he
did like
um uh Sunny Higgins was the biggest the
head [__] over the [__] and so but
and he he played everything his way
you're gonna you're gonna do what I say
I'll get you put away from you all I had
you killed you know he don't like Uncle
Thomas we call him now but you know he
he one of them kinds did you ever meet
him no I I never met him because they
know my mom would have ran away and
that's how they ended up in Shreveport
you know you never know if you're like
doing a little Discovery or our last
name there's no Hagens in Louisiana
I got a cousin there he was adopted too
and he played professional basketball he
overseas now
um I got another cousin that uh no he
think he's my uncle I'm not for sure
what he is kid to me but I think he's my
uncle but he played for tell me
Buccaneers and so me and him kind of
really tight we kept up with each other
you know through my college days and
stuff like that me coming back home and
going to jail
he's always you know I mean I just
always talk about it and then it's a
free one but they're all in Florida or
in Georgia
you know any doubt like the first time I
went to Porterville to that Plantation
over there with them they um
they they they they they was glad to see
me but they was on something else though
herself they like because they're like
they feel like you know I was driving up
in the truck and I looked at good okay
this [__] got some money
how old were you then I was 19 maybe and
you were just going to Port you were
just going there for what just go go
just see where where I come from yeah
and and man everybody look alike
wow I think about everybody look like I
got to buy from the the old man sitting
at the little little butcher shop
sitting there but they said that looks
like you yeah hey somebody
um the cousin that I that I met over the
Internet that lived there I like I
stayed there with them actually so this
is like 20 years ago yeah yeah yeah and
and what what like what were the
conditions like there I mean you say it
was asleep
it was like all all handmade shotgun
houses right and it was like like a big
row of them and they started to feel
still down is it is it area is there
anything around here that's kind of like
it was it totally different than
Shreveport or was it like
it reminded me of the bottoms you know
and they also my all the Shacks all the
way and then um uh so many people and
then they got a a a brick a brick made
building with cinder blocks data
somebody built on the store making a
killing in in that neighborhood you know
that's the only store right there for
miles away you know and this man they
bring somebody bringing fresh produce
for them and they still living like I
guess people just staying recognize that
I can get away from here yeah
[Music]
all right
foreign
what's going on everybody it's John and
Bam Bam the dog uh first on behalf of
both of us and everybody from the real
ones team I just want to sincerely thank
you guys for for tuning in the folks
that I bring on the show they're family
to me and uh being able to tell their
stories and bringing you into their
world something I'm I'm just super proud
of and uh again grateful that you guys
tune in we've decided we want to take
things just a step further it's a
patreon community and basically what
that means is if you become a part of
this community look I already bored Bam
Bam if you want to become a part of this
community you're going to be able to
hear episodes early and all that ad free
and all that good stuff but there's all
this behind the scenes footage all this
stuff that we've shot that really brings
you into the folks that we've had on the
show really brings you into their world
live chats with me and the folks that I
bring on the show to talk about their
world talk about the issues that they're
dealing with but their triumphs and
their tragedies just go to patreon slash
real ones on this website that you see
right there right on the screen that's
right in front of you this whole idea
year was something about building
bridges and and bringing people together
and bringing folks that often don't get
the mic and giving the mic to them so
the fact that you guys tuned in means
the world anyways again thank you be
good to each other out there rock and
roll